-Earlier tonight,
I got to talk to my first guest
about today's events.
He's a multiple Emmy and Peabody
Award-winning journalist
and "The New York Times"
best-selling author
of "What Unites Us."
Here is my conversation with
the one and only Dan Rather.
Dan, thank you so much
for being here tonight.
-Jimmy, thank you
for having me on.
It's a privilege and an honor
to be with you. Thank you.
-We thought the big news
of the day
was going to be
how things went in Georgia
and with
the electoral-vote count,
but then this afternoon, Trump
supporters stormed the Capitol.
And we're talking a few hours
before this will air,
but could you give us
a breakdown
of what happened today
and where things stand now
as events continue to unfold?
-Well, things are continuing
to unfold.
During the evening,
I expect they will continue
even deep into
the early morning hours
because this has been
an absolutely --
and frequently overworked word
but an apt word in this case.
This is an absolutely
unprecedented situation
for our country and one --
and a very serious situation.
Basically what happened was
that, increasingly, it appeared
that the two Democratic
candidates were winning
and had won the Senate
runoff races in Georgia.
This would, of course,
mean that the Democrats
would have effective control
of the Senate
in the new Biden administration.
So, that news didn't
really get solidified
until the wee hours
of early this morning.
After that,
there was a rally planned
in front of the White House,
a pro-Trump rally.
The President --
I use the word "incited" it.
You can't use any other word.
Incited the crowd
to march down to the Capitol
and to force a delay
in the certification
of Biden's victory.
That was to be the other
big headline of the day.
The big headline of the day
was expected to be Democrats
win two Senate races in Georgia
and the combined Congressional
power in the country
certifying
the final electoral votes.
Even as Vice President Pence
was presiding in the chamber
and the final certification
of the Biden victory
was getting under way,
then this crowd
stormed the U.S. Capitol.
You can describe it
as "protesters," if you like.
I, myself, think
they were certainly rioters.
They broke windows.
They were violent.
They stormed the Capitol.
They stormed actually
into the room where --
the chamber, where
the deliberation was happening.
All hell broke loose.
There was no law and there
was no order for a while.
You had mob violence
inside the Capitol
of the United States.
Now finally the law-enforcement
officers, first of all,
they got some reinforcements.
Secondly, they sort of
solidified their own response.
And most, if not all,
of what I call the rioters
were put outside the Capitol.
It's a little hard to say what
the situation is at this moment,
and I emphasize that it's fluid.
But here's the thing, Jimmy.
We have never seen this
in our country before --
an effort to overthrow
the legitimate vote
of the people
in a presidential election.
This was by
any dictionary definition
a coup attempt, which is to say,
"Okay, we've had an election.
We, this mob, we don't agree
with the outcome
of the election,
which even the courts
have certified in their own way.
And we're going to overturn it."
That's a definition of a coup,
and I do think
this could be described
as a case of domestic violence.
Not everybody in this crowd
of people were violent today.
Not nearly everybody.
But there certainly
were outright rioters
who were taking part
in domestic violence,
and the overall scene
was one of a coup attempt.
It has failed.
That's pretty much where we are.
-Do you think there will be
charges against these people?
-Well, let's be very clear.
There should be
because if you break windows
in the U.S. Capitol
and go in and occupy the offices
of elected representatives
of the country,
those are crimes.
Whether they will be
prosecuted or not,
frankly, I have my doubts
as time goes along.
But there is a movement
to try to identify those people
who were actually breaking
windows and occupying offices
and bring charges against them.
But the real important question
of the moment, Jimmy,
and I think this will play out
over the next few days,
is what is to be done about the
president of the United States?
Make no mistake --
there are talks in the Capitol
among some Republicans,
including some Democrats,
of should some move be made
to remove President Trump
from office
in just his last 13 days?
He only has 13 more days
in office.
That shows you how serious
the situation is.
I'm not saying that any
of that's going to happen.
You know, under the 25th
Amendment to the Constitution,
if the Vice President
and a majority
of the cabinet secretaries
agree that the President
is not capable
or won't carry out his duties,
then they can ask the Congress
to have a vote in both houses
to remove the President.
That's a major step.
I wouldn't go so far as to say
that we can expect
that step to happen,
but it gives you an indication,
again, of how serious this is,
when you have
that kind of serious talk
in the Capitol
of the United States.
It's the result
of this unprecedented day
in which as a country,
as a people,
we embarrassed ourselves.
-How --
-In the eyes of the world,
we clearly embarrassed
ourselves.
-How much is President Trump
to blame for what happened today
and who else is to blame?
-Well, I'll give you
my opinion, Jimmy,
but, you know, I always like
to be straight with you.
There are plenty of people
who have other opinions,
but I think that history
is going to judge
that President Trump
primarily is responsible
for what happened today.
The power of the presidency
is a power
to inspire and/or to incite.
And, clearly, President Trump
has been trying to incite
just this kind of action.
There's no -- You know,
I don't see that there's
any real argument about it.
The argument can be, "Well,
he was justified in doing it,"
which is a false argument.
But the direct answer
to your question --
that the buck starts
with President Trump,
and it goes through
those members of his party,
the Republican Party.
Not all members
of the Republican Party,
but, really, a large majority of
members of the Republican Party
have aided
and abetted the President
in convincing a large section
of the American public
that Joe Biden would be
an illegitimate president,
that the election
was not legitimate
and Biden wasn't
legitimately elected.
It started with the President.
It goes through
his enablers and allies
and people within
the Republican Party.
And then, again, frankly,
Jimmy, none of us can say
that we don't share
at least some of the blame
because we have let this happen.
We have reached
this point in our history
where we have
an undisciplined mob,
including some rioters
and domestic terrorism,
storming our own Capitol.
Exclamation point.
-Were you surprised to see
how easy it was for them
to break into the Capitol?
-I was surprised.
Perhaps, I shouldn't have been,
but I thought, frankly,
that a combination
of the Capitol police
and the Washington police
and federal forces,
such as the FBI and others,
would have a plan
for meeting this kind of effort
to a mob take over the Capitol,
so I was surprised
that law enforcement
was not more effective.
In the early going,
it was not effective at all.
But before we criticize
the law-enforcement officers,
I want to know
what instructions they had.
I don't know what instructions
they had.
In the early going, they just --
they fled the mob.
They just --
They absolutely fled.
They just fled --
The law-enforcement officers,
that Capitol police, and others
there just fled the scene.
After a while, they began
to try to get control,
but in the early going,
the performance was very poor.
But, again, that may be
on orders from some other place,
including, you know,
somebody in the Capitol
who's in charge of the force.
We just have to see.
But, you know,
as we speak now, Jimmy,
the National Guard
has been called in.
I think a strong case
could be made
given the consequences of today
that the National Guard
should have been standing by
as this day started
because President Trump had
already scheduled that rally.
But nonetheless, order is
being restored in the Capitol.
The National Guard is now there.
Things will probably
simmer down somewhat
over the next 12 to 24 hours,
but we as a country,
as a people,
we're stuck with the question,
"What do we do now?"
We know this is embarrassing.
We know this is not
the American way.
We know it's perilous.
It's very dangerous
to have this situation prevail.
So the question is,
what do we do now?
-There's lots more
I want to talk to you about.
More with Dan Rather
when we come back
to "The Tonight Show,"
everybody.
-Thank you, Jimmy.